time now for cbs morning's deals and
this week we have three items for the
outdoors that might just become
essentials in your everyday life and
they are all at exclusive low prices to
start shopping now all you got to do you
may know this already scan the qr code
on your screen it's there in the upper
left and you can also visit cbsdeals.com
to help us along we've got lifestyle
expert elizabeth werner uh with more on
all of it okay this looks like something
perfect for tailgating a lot of people
got grills in the backyard you can't
travel with it though this you can right
that's right so this is a portable grill
it's actually a charcoal grill so you
know close your eyes
smell that smell from when you were
young right so your food's going to have
that delicious flavor you can pick this
up bring it everywhere it comes with
everything you need including a carry
bag and yes this lid we can see through
so when we're cooking we don't have to
open up the lid and let all the heat out
i actually just brought this to a
friend's house i made up some turkey
burgers before i went i said i've got my
grill byog i brought my grill pulled it
open lit it up made my turkey burgers we
were dancing we'll get to that in a
minute we had so much fun so it's easy
to use and when you touch it on the
outside here when it's when it's warm
this stays cool so if you've got kids
right you don't want them to
yes so it's 99 that's a hundred dollars
savings wow bring it with you everywhere
you don't like beef burgers i am a
turkey burger girl
but you can cook beef burgers you can
make anything on here the surface is
huge
it's got that charcoal yummy charcoal
flavors
i saw you guys while you're taking
pictures of your grill time and sending
it to friends and saying come on out
here you're running down your phone
battery yeah
yes and so that's the worst thing for
all of us when our phones actually run
out well this is the lvl and this is a
little portable charger so we take it it
goes with any device you have so it
doesn't matter what phone you have
there's a special device for each you
plug it right in it gives us 19 extra
hours of talk time photo time so i like
the size of it elizabeth it's so small
and no cable charging no cables so this
is great so you actually just plug it
right in it's got a a little usb
you plug it into the wall at night you
charge this put your phone right onto
this you're charging both at once then
when you head out for your day your busy
day wherever you're going you bring it
along with you in your pocket in your
little purse
yeah
all the kids need it we don't want them
telling us that 15 hours this is 19
extra hours of talk time so definitely
something to bring with you wherever you
go
that's the words when you run out so
yeah this is actually 45 off it's 27 and
50 cents
take it with you everywhere you were
pink one there you go
it's got some nude lighting over there
so you were talking about grilling yes
and when you like to grill you like to
set the ambiance you know i like to
dance and party and have something this
is something
nate about elizabeth
so this can light up the mood but also
light at the party with that's right
these are tiki tunes you notice the
ambiance right here it looks like a
little flame it's an led light we're not
burning ourselves on this but this is
also
what oh wow speaker you're getting i
don't know if that's good music for a
party i feel like
for our party
i'm like what kind of party is this
[Music]
these are actual speakers and you know
what the minute we turn them on we're
giving two today instead of one turn
them in they pair with each other we've
got surround sound we can have them 30
feet apart indoors outdoors and they're
also coming with these four foot tall
stakes so you can put them outside like
i had them get the music going get the
grill going so yeah and these are
phenomenal so normally you just get one
now you're gonna get two today including
with both of the steaks and these are
59.99 buy one get one free you're
getting all of it you're getting the yep
the posts that look like little bamboo
posts both of the speakers indoors
outdoors
you're getting two for actually less
than the price of one and getting the
stakes the chargers these are chargeable
so we don't have to like battery them up
we just recharge them at night so this
brings a party wherever you are inside
all time i just i think you need some
help on your musical choice what i bet
your feels hairy style singing over
there yeah
that's right that's exactly right but
you want to go to a party and you hear
we love the cbs theme song don't get me
wrong it's great if you want to hear
that at a party no i'm gonna mix it up
but i like all these items they actually
work together right
here we go if you like anything you saw
you want to buy it scan the qr code on
your screen they are rocking out and
dancing i'm glad we are covered for this
you can also visit cbsdeals.com